[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum Ryan hi Hi how are you
good how are you good your hair is a
little longer it is gross fast it's been
a month yeah yeah is it time for a
haircut uh it'll be time for a haircut
at the beginning of June so that it
grows out at a reasonable length for my
sister's wedding oh congratulations I
don't want to have like a too short
haircut I want it to be like do you
think people are excited to hear about
your hair right now yes
especially if they're listening uh great
episode before we start it uh you're
gonna love this one I'm so glad I was
such a big fan of her I still am a big
fan of hers after this interview
um Paul Abdul but before you fast
forward um I just let you know that uh
patreon.com inside of you facebook.com
inside of you to support the podcast I
thank you all the patrons for really
supporting us and keeping it going I
want to do it I'd love to do it forever
so if you wanted to continue and you're
liking these interviews uh support us if
you can and uh if you can't at least uh
listen and write a review follow us on
our handles Ryan at inside if you pod on
Twitter outside of your podcast on
Instagram and Facebook yes that's right
uh inside of the online store I still
have a few of those Lex Luthor statues
they just went on sale they're bronze
they're art pieces I sign them their
number there's only nine I think there's
like four left and if you want one get
one but there's a lot of other cool
stuff autograph lexma scripts and talk
are inside of you mugs and and uh tons
of stuff so get there inside your online
store and uh also I'm going to be in
Tidewater and then I'm in Virginia Beach
Recon I'm going to be in Niagara Falls
coming up I'm going to be in Philly
um so get out there to see me damn it
Wally and I will be in Philly to do a uh
a Smallville nights in a con drink some
water yeah have a Philly cheesesteak oh
yeah what am I doing that accent I don't
know I don't know uh Paul Abdul what can
I say about her I mean I just love rush
rush wanna hear him be with me I have so
many songs that I just love that she did
and um she has so many great stories
that I had no idea her Laker story is
unreal
um I think we should just get into it
um
all my love to you guys let's just let's
just rock into this no no too much
talking let's get inside of Paula
freaking Abdul it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenberg
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
Ryan before you got here I was doing my
research you know my quick kind of like
scan of the Earth for my guests to see
you know what they've done and obviously
we know some of what you've done but
it's like endless the amount of [__]
you've done
I mean don't you ever get tired
um yeah I do but I figure I'll sleep a
whole bunch later on when I go
do you sleep well
um that's a really I have not slept at
all like last night I was I was up on
that like bad insomnia I go through
bouts of insomnia like every six weeks
or so and it usually lasts like two to
three days and I'm a Zombie so I was
like one of all days I'm coming here for
my first podcast you don't look like a
zombie you're the most beautiful zombie
I've ever seen well you're so kind that
should be a movie beautiful zombie has
it already been done
probably Apocalypse Zombie I'm sure
that's been done
um bloated bloated bloated zombies yes I
think that's been done I think that's my
brother the bloated zombie I thought so
he looked a little bloated the other day
hey fatty we were in Vegas oh yeah I
said that we were talking about uh
that's an inside joke it's just like you
know did you be honest about this did
you always have like aspirations of
being like a rock star in this amazing
dancer choreographer did you even dream
about that as a kid or was it something
that just kind of kept happening
this is crazy because let me back it up
I was born three months premature I
weighed 2.8 pounds
I had terrible hip dysplasia and in
dance you have to have turned out hips
but I had braces on my legs completely
inverted like old school braces I had I
was born with a broken windpipe so the
almost the first three full years of my
life I was the first fainting goat like
I was fainted all the time if I wake up
when baby cries they make the face and
they it's an inhale and I couldn't even
hold that so I would pass out what yeah
and I have a sister who's seven years
older than I am her name's Wendy I love
her to death but because I was the freak
of nature that came along ruined her
life because she's seven and a half and
now this little peanut that everyone's
afraid to touch and she can't play with
me but what was cool is that
she would escape the dinner table and go
into my room and provoke me to wake up
because she was adamant that damn it I'm
gonna play with my baby sister
but what she did which was interesting
and the doctor said like she just taught
you like a life coping mechanism as soon
as she provoked me to wake up and I'd
make that face go she'd go tickle me and
she'd go and she tickled me and I'd like
you remember this this is no this is
what I was told that's what you're told
us gosh and and laughing is an exhale
we're crying is an inhale
sometimes it just kind of leaks out of a
laugh and it's embarrassing catches me
by surprise but I learned to laugh all
the time so when I get punished I'd
laugh
that's not good but seriously like I was
four years old
I do remember I do remember glimpses of
this
and my family sat down to watch an MGM
musical called singing in the ring oh
yeah
and I remember seeing because I it's
something that ignited and like it's
that spark ignited and changed my life
at four years old I remember walking up
to the TV set and pointing the two
second going that's my dad to Gene Kelly
and my dad behind on the couch said no
I'm your father that could be your TV
dad
and at that point my family said that I
said I'm going to do that I'm going to
beat that at four years old I knew what
my life calling was and I never looked
back I like I knew
like a child believes in Santa Claus
that that's what I was going to do so
you had everything going against you but
you're like you're four years old and
you look at the TV and it's singing the
rain you're like oh this is me as a
little kid at four years old Ryan what
are you doing I'm going you know my
dad's you know looking at me like what
the what's wrong with you that's what I
was I was what's wrong with me that's
the big question I always was wondering
as a kid what is wrong with me why do
they keep asking me that what the hell
is wrong with you what's wrong with you
why are you doing that I don't know and
so I felt like
finally acting was sort of a home where
I could kind of be anything I wanted to
be and be provocative and get away with
it I'm an actor I can do whatever the
hell I want sort of
um but you sort of know so so take me
through or were you starting like always
dancing in the house and playing around
and well okay so were your parents cool
did you have good parents okay so let me
tell great parents both completely like
served as a major purpose in my life my
mom was tough love
my mother was uh one of the most
celebrated pianists and she'd learned to
play by key and she was celebrated in
she's Canadian in in the philharmonics
on radio shows and the first thing she
said to my sister and I you can play any
instrument but you're not playing the
piano
because she didn't want to have the
headache of hearing my mom is born with
perfect pitch and the best thing just
Smash Cartoon when my mom would come to
American Idol I could see her
peripherally and if I heard one of the
contestants go sharp reflect I would
look at my mom and this is my mom would
go like this
and um but so my mom was very particular
that you're not playing the piano
so my sister took up guitar and I
decided I'm going to play the tuba
you played the tuba no that was a
disaster then I went to Upright bass
he's so small upright bass I just leaned
it against the wall okay good but then I
fell in love with the flute and in
Orchestra and band I'd be fainting all
the time and the rest of the class would
be counting like wagering bets of okay
how long is she gonna be out for it
let's like from just playing the flute
breath you lose your breath and you pass
out
dancing pass out
I'm telling you Chris I constantly pass
out yeah it's um it was it was really
weird you are that fainting goat I
what's the first painting is that what
it is or sheep it's a goat it's a goat
it's a goat thanks you know it's a goat
but but the craziest thing is
this is shows the tenacity of of a
fighter because I bought it from birth
I became first chair flautist all
throughout Junior High and High School
and um I was determined like you know
certain things I couldn't do in PE class
because I couldn't run it just
but I learned to have create my own
style of dance because because of my
body and having the hip dysplasia I
never was born with with the extension
and the flexibility as dancers but I had
a keen mind that would dream like
full-blown production numbers in my
sleep and and like like in polaroid
pictures you know or I say polaroid
pictures Polaroid you get that Ryan my
my mom was tough love she worked for the
studios
um so she worked for the president of
United Artists and Warner Brothers and
so she saw a gazillion young girls well
ingenues all these people want to make
it and the hardship of it and my family
they're doctors and lawyers and it's
like you're gonna go to school be that
and I would say okay but not really and
my dad was the other one and said
as a little girl
God damn it you're an Abdul you can do
anything you goddamn want to do and I
thought God damn what's like the coolest
thing that was a good
and then God damn you're an abdomen so
here's the perfect visual of my mom and
my dad I'm I'm in first grade and I'm
starring in the spring musical called
Jill in the Box
and I'm messing up
and I look out into the audience and I
see my mom like this
oh God nightmare this is my dad
gets up he's going excuse me and he's
passing by people excuse me excuse me
and I'm watching my dad and now he's
walking towards this stage and now he's
on the side of the Wings and he's going
get over here and I'm like shuffling off
the Buffalo to my dad on the stage
God damn it go out there and show them
who you are you're a goddamn Abdul
I went okay
okay my dad was my cheerleader my mom
was just wanting to make sure that her
daughter doesn't get overwhelmed with
rejection from trying to make it in the
business and my dad always said God damn
it you can do whatever you want but he
did tell me at nine years old because
I'd say Dad I'm going to make it one day
I don't know how but somehow I'm gonna
make it and he said honey I think we
need to talk
you're not going to be the obvious
choice in the nicest way he's trying to
tell me you're never going to fit the
mold and I'm listening to him intently
he goes
you're gonna get rejected which means
you're gonna feel bad but it's okay it
doesn't matter
just remember this
no is the beginning of a negotiation
oh my God eight and a half turning nine
and I carried it with me for the rest of
my life Jesus were you
but I have to tell you one can I just
tell you the crazy aspect of where I
grew up yeah North Hollywood
and I was in a three three condominium
compound
right where the old Van Nuys and Victory
Drive-In was cold water
and this is crazy we lived in the middle
condominium our condominium was
separated by a pool and my sister's High
School boyfriend I was seven my sister
was at Grant High School and her
boyfriend was this genius Savant drummer
like incredible
his older brother or cousin I don't
someone how related to him was the band
leader so there's a little nepotism
going on but they're like my sister
white Jewish kid named Mark Sanders
great guy
and one day
he gets a phone call from the band
leader saying my old college roommate
don't know if you remember him he's now
the MD of the Jacksons they're opening
up at the MGM Grand the MD what's MD
musical director oh sorry about that
yeah well I should know that probably
shouldn't I anyway well you know what an
ad is
I wonder if she met MC so the musical
director right I'm not a doctor either
no not a doctor wasn't a doctor a doctor
of Music well but uh
Mark said well I'm white and I'm Jewish
and and they go yeah we're well aware of
it and they're fine with that and my
mother loaded up the station wagon
he learned the entire set for the
Jacksons they were open at the MGM Grand
we drove in the station wagon my very
first concert at seven years old
was the Jacksons Ten Years Later
I'm a Laker girl and I'm choreographing
their world tour the reunion tour with
Michael
this episode of inside of you is brought
to you by better help better help online
therapy so many people have come to me
at these cons telling me better help is
really changing their life it's really
helping them it means a ton to me that
they're you know using something that I
promote
um and it's just such it's so good for
you and you know a lot of people Ryan
you know I don't want people I could
deal with my problems I I got it and
they just bottle up man and when it gets
too much
you'll you implode you you just you know
we all need therapy you you go to
therapy yeah you continue to go to
therapy it's like yeah it's like a
weekly sort of release valve it is
that's a good way of looking at it yeah
um look with everything happening around
us it could be hard to focus on our
well-being many are stretched thin and
burned out from burning the candle at
both ends I know I do that
you know you got so much going on you
think you can handle it and uh that's
where therapy comes in caring
compassionate listeners like those at
betterhelp.com this totally online
source for therapy has helped thousands
find peace of mind and Direction during
these trying times betterhelp.com
understands we all need to develop
better coping skills and ways to set
boundaries to empower us to become the
best versions of ourselves let me
recommend betterhelp.com if you've
considered trying therapy after a brief
questionnaire and it is brief trust me
it's quick yeah I don't like long stuff
you'll be matched with a licensed
therapist and you can switch at any time
at no charge
that's the thing I think people like
what if I don't like my therapist it's
so easy done new one see ya
get someone you Vibe if you have to go
through five so be it
find more balance with better help visit
betterhelp.com inside today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside
do you know everybody oh it's almost
like it's really like one of those it's
like the Jack Nicholson stories and like
but the Paula Abdul is all it's it's
wedged in history as like that almost
like folklore that thing was like she
was like a girl Paula Abdul was a Laker
girl and that's what started a career
and all these things and I whenever I go
to the game I always laugh I go I want
to be the guy who announces the Laker
Girls this is all he does literally goes
liquor girls
yes that's all he does the famous
Lawrence Tanner is that his name Tanner
yeah liquor girls you know how I became
a Lego girl oh you're hot you could
dance hardly hardly well I could dance
um
this was fun a fun story again not the
obvious choice I used to teach dance and
cheerleading camps once teenager and
some of the girls that were on staff
with me 17 17 years old
these beautiful five foot seven you know
the figure for days blonde hair blue
eyes
they come they go
hey Polly do you want to try out to be a
Laker girl with us and I'd look up at
them I go no like why not
because I'm I don't look like you I
don't fit the mold but you're so good
Paula come on what do you have to lose
and that was a challenge to me I said
nothing I suppose and uh four girls
picked me up we carpooled all the way to
the none of them got it you got it well
no but I you had to be 18 I was 17 and a
half okay so I remember when we got down
there I bought a dance bag with me and I
noticed the other girls didn't they just
had their leotards and we were walking
in and I was number we were in the 700s
there were close to 2 000 girls and
they'd line up a hundred at a time at
the Forum
and
I was subbing at 742 and the other four
girls were relatively around that number
with me and I remember on my toes and
I'm I'm hitting my hips they go okay if
we call your number please step forward
and numbers are being called and then
two of my friends like one after another
got called and I'm going and I'm like
yeah like that and then my number's
called
and the other two girls weren't called
and I'm just going oh my God and I'm on
my tiptoes they go uh state your name I
go Paula Abdul spell it abdull by Kareem
Abdul-Jabbar
sure whatever
they go how tall are you I go five foot
two
I'm five at nothing
so lie lie lie lie
but
this is the coolest part I think we're
going to be able to dance and move
forward and the rest are gonna be cut
you hear the voice from God going all
right ladies we have to thin the herd if
we called your number thank you for
coming down come back next season and
try out wait you were the guys the girls
that weren't weren't didn't even get to
dance okay
I'm like going I can't believe I didn't
even get to dance aren't you guys pissed
that now three of us were cut two girls
so that the two girls I thought were
being cut they're left and I just go
I'll be right back I went into the
bathroom because no I had a plan I
certainly did I put on a different
leotard
I put I got a different number I had my
hair down so now when I only put it in a
ponytail and I entered as my middle name
Julie you cheater
and I spelled my last name a b b a l
funniest thing is there's there was a
guy that actually saw me do this and I'm
going how in the hell can one person
hone in looking at me and laughing and I
went out of the bathroom and the two
girls that were cut with me they're like
you can't do it I went by and I ran out
onto the form floor right up to my two
friends were there and they're all
they're negotiating
can't do that Paula this is against the
rules I go
my dad taught me if it's not written in
the rules there are no rules
right so I I entered as my middle name
Julie Apple new number put my hair in a
ponytail
I got to dance and all three of us got
cut so now all five of us are done Gonzo
and all that they're pissed off is that
the two girls I originally got cut are
mad at me now the other two girls are
they're mad at me and I'm going aren't
you mad that we got cut and I said guys
please can you just wait one more round
I still have one more outfit no come on
I'm not kidding I'm not kidding did you
did you know this she changed into
another effing out but I saved the best
for last what did you put on well first
of all I said can you wait and they said
hell no you can take a taxi or a bus and
I went really like a really and I went
okay I went back into the stall this
time I saved the best for last night the
old Jane Fonda red and white chevron
strike leotard
blue leg warmers oh no I don't you were
17 I don't want to see pictures
yeah
um wristbands and now I had a headband
like Olivia Newton John and I'm like
okay dear God please I gotta get this I
gotta become a Laker girl I gotta I got
it proved to my dad like as if this is
gonna make my career little did I know
uh I ran out there and as I was running
out of the bathroom
oh I entered
my first initial p
my middle initial J spelled my last name
Apple a-p-p-l-e
Paula Julie apple and what am I going to
do with my hair I've worn it down I put
it in a ponytail
I'm gonna put half up and half down with
a hair scrunchie I started the worst
hair craze ever the half up half down
palm tree on the head it all started as
me trying to figure out how it could
look different to be a Lego girl got a
different number as I ran out of the
bathroom I heard back half of the Arena
come forward and the front half go back
and it was perfect I just ran to the
front in the middle
this guy is still laughing at me a gun
guy who ended up being an intern from
UCLA who got their job of of being in
charge of the Laker Girls
his name was Lon Rosen I know lawn Lon
Rosen was my first boss well I swear to
God I know long he's a good guy to know
he got me a Dodger tickets yes because
he's been he's been in the business
as her intern then stuck with magic
became his agent his manager like and
and has everything to do with the
Dodgers and it's just crazy so
I got to dance
and then I heard front half of the Arena
go back and back half go front and at
that moment I'm pivoting I'm gonna I'm
going they're gonna forget about me God
damn they're gonna forget about me and I
said I promise to God I'd be bold and
daring and I literally turned around and
I ran back squirmed my way to the front
and center and Lon was laughing
and uh that's how I made it I got the
third attempt you
I mean and I became the tenacity but
that's
risk taking here's the difference you
notice this
because I like to get in mental health
and stuff like that on this podcast
because a lot of people go through it
and a lot of people really responding we
Face adversity we face it the stigma's
going away with mental health and I like
that finally but we have a long way to
go but I look at you as like this young
teenage
girl who's just going for it and and has
just no fear very little fear and let me
ask you why is it that when we get older
oh it creeps up on us like all this
confidence and all these things that we
exude like that make us who we are then
start peeling us or breaking us down
it's the most difficult thing to sustain
because when we start
we we don't care how we do it we are
just going to figure out how to how to
make it so you have Reckless abandon and
you have that that's that I have nothing
to lose and so you don't then when you
start becoming famous and recognized you
start having things to lose and then it
chips away at that Reckless abandon and
that that what do I have to lose
mentality it's the hardest thing to come
back but it you have to find a balance
in that otherwise when you come back
from it yes can you really come back
from it and be stronger even than you
were
well that's called uh having the Ebbs
and flows in your career and and
creating renaissances
of reinvention at all the time and I
I've been that girl you know you
certainly have and I've gone through
tremendous adversity and
you know when I stated I stayed I was
made the head Laker girl and
choreographer right away because the
girl who was in charge named Lori Ryan
um fell in love with another basketball
player and got traded and um
I think that was the story and she was
moving so immediately I I took over and
I was of course I was like the little
short one right now I'm probably nervous
like oh my gosh I'm this is a big you
know you know what I I knew
that I I always knew that I had a gift
of creation and and forming something
like like okay so my condominium not
only did Mark Sanders my sister's
boyfriend go on to be a famous musician
and the Jacksons and all that two doors
down were these two brothers named the
picaro brothers
and then there were four College
roommates in the first condominium that
ended up becoming members of the the
tower power horn section
so this is all in my North Hollywood and
I'm a girl little girl who would get I
would get the musicians and go into the
playground at the back of the three
Condominiums and I'd I'd direct and
produce the spring musicals and the
Christmas plays and I had a knack for
putting things together organizing and
seeing a full that was your gift that
was not a gift for that yeah for seeing
things and creating things and movement
and all these there's there's one person
that I left out that was very um
influential well how do I say
influential I couldn't stand him he was
my babysitter
um I was seven years old my my sister
and her best friend Maureen worked at
this in the mall of this store called
Contempo County by the way drink some
water you haven't stopped talking I feel
bad you're talking so much am I if and
if I'm if I'm overwhelming or boring
just no this is awesome I just was like
I feel bad because I keep like throwing
this stuff at you you just want to open
up about it I love it the babysitter the
babysitter so my sister's best friend
Maureen they they worked at a place
called Contempo casuals which was a
clothing store very hip back in the
Laurel Canyon Mall okay the Laurel Plaza
whatever
um so when they when they were working
I'd have I'd my I'd my mom would have to
get a babysitter but see my sister's
best friend Maureen had a boyfriend who
was inspiring inspiring
singer-songwriter from Westport
Connecticut
and in the Summers he'd come out and
he'd spend half the time with Maureen
and her family his girlfriend's family
waiting to see this and the other Kathy
he would also stay with my sister and
hang out they were best friends
and I used to hate when he babysit me
because
he's an aspiring singer-songwriter he
would always go I'm just gonna be
outside I mean I know he's going to be
with the per car over but he's gonna be
with the musicians are gonna and he pays
no attention to me and I remember I was
so angry at him at seven years old and
I'm a brat in my brownie uniform I'm
doing my homework on an L-shaped couch
and he goes to leap and I ran on my
knees to lock him out but my pencil from
doing my homework it was stuck up in
between the cushions went into my knee
and this this inspiring
singer-songwriter who had his driver's
permit I had to get stitches in my knee
his name was Michael baloton who became
Michael Bolton
I can't make this [__] I can't make this
[__] up
this podcast is brought to you by Dove
men plus care guys do you get distracted
during the day thinking about your
underarm sweating or itching or emitting
an odor oh
do those thoughts keep you from showing
care when it counts new and improved
Dove men plus care antiperspirant with
72-hour sweat and odor protection and
one quarter moisturizing cream helps you
forget about your underarms so you can
be present for the moments that matter
don't let underarm insecurities keep you
at arm's distance from the ones you care
about buy new and improved Dove men plus
care antiperspirant wherever personal
care products are sold this message is
sponsored by discover did you know you
could reduce the number of unwanted
calls and emails with online privacy
protection the latest Innovation from
discover discover will help regularly
remove your personal info like your name
and address from 10 popular people
search websites that could sell your
data and they'll do it for free
activate in the Discover app see terms
and learn more at discover.com online
privacy protection Michael Bolton was
your babysitter now smash cut to
years later
all of a sudden straight up it's a
number one thing
sorry yes damn but remember he's babysit
means sing me lullabies to Beatles songs
and I kept you up with that voice and
he'd sing he'd sing and use farm animals
for Twist and Shout he'd do twist and
moo
are you still friends with him okay so
all these years go by you dated him oh
God no okay all right well I mean you
know that's that's the funny part
because I can't make this [__] up no I'm
driving it and straight up is now number
one single we are driving my sister are
getting our nails done on Sunset at
Jessica nail salon
we are passing at right at a light
before Tower Records my sister goes oh
my God the whole side of the wall is my
album
I've never seen anything like that the
whole like big the whole forever your
girl album oh my God and at the at the
red light next to me you hear straight
up being blasted and these girls are
like lip syncing and scream and then
they see me and I they see me and scream
I go ah and my sister's gone this is so
weird because I was Wendy Abdul's little
sister all the time and it was just a
weird transition when this happened
because I love it now
it's so crazy we pass the light and
we're laughing because it's such just
bizarre still I'm trying to get used to
the fact that my song's on the radio
and she flips the station and we it's
about it my sister because
do you remember beloten I go
yeah she goes just kind of sounds like
him very distinct voice right
they back announce and that was Michael
Bolton from the Hunger album
my sister turns the car around pulls
into Tower Records we go right in
straight to Michael Bolton and theirs
has been and he has the same damn mullet
hairdo that he that he had it's him
at the same exact time with my little
flip phone I get a call from my one of
my good friends Julie who became the
first ever dance agent
she goes what are you doing I go I'm
Wendy and I are getting our nails done I
go why don't you meet us she goes I'll
see if I can get an appointment she goes
I have something weird to tell you I
just got a call from a manager uh named
Mr Levin Lewis Levin
and he has a client and the first thing
he says you need to can you please find
out if if she's the brat that he used to
babysit
I go huh she goes a guy named Michael
well I go I'm standing in front of his
bin I go Julie I'm putting on speaker
Wendy come over here come over here what
what yeah and I go say what you just
said Julie a guy a manager who has a an
artist uh he his name is Michael Bolton
and and I go Julie I'm standing in front
of his bed I go tell him I'm not the
brat she goes wait a minute he babysat
you I go get good I'm not kidding my
sister and I I said I'll meet at the
sunset Marquee wants me at 4 P.M my
sister and I hadn't seen him since I was
seven since she was 17 18. and you went
and had lunch no we went to the sunset
Marquis at 4pm he came out of the
elevator he sees my sister and I drops
to his knees and we ended up staying and
talking until four in the morning and it
ended up being wait a minute he was like
you little [__] my whole career I am
just now
having a hit like with the adult
contemporary fear of album has to be out
and he goes you little [__] and I go
sorry it's sorry I go what do you I go
what is what you want me to choreograph
you like he goes well yeah I go my
sister goes you have no rhythm my five
can recall correctly and I just started
laughing and and he goes You Gotta Give
me something and then he goes and by the
way I'm nominated at the American Music
Awards will you be my date
is nominated for best new male artist
and I go ew my sister's laughing and
then it was just come on do it fine I
I'm his date for the American Music
Awards
what does Dick Clark give me as a
category best new male artist
I was laughing with Michael Bolton
I announced his win it's first his first
American score this universe is small as
vast as it appears to be it's amazing
how it's like Celestine Prophecy shits
it is it's weird kind of
this energy that we create and it's
this this didn't happen when I was a kid
I grew up somewhere where the guy behind
me was caught in an aluminum Shredder
and died another guy went to prison
another guy uh went to prison for you
know killing somebody uh there was a
there was no CR a lot of very no
creativity where I grew up in Indiana
the fact that I got out and there was
like I can't go and then who do I bump
into
the guy who murdered the guy in high
school
[Laughter]
yeah that made his parole officer asked
me to come over and talk anyway
um you and I share something that
um you could elaborate on but I have
since I was 18 I've had a lot of
surgeries I've had a lot of chronic pain
a double chronic pain my entire life
I've had eight
no one no one no one understands it no
one unless they've gone through it no
one gets it I um like I said six lower
back surgeries fusion fusion in my neck
you know Sports and that and I still
function and I I try not to talk about
it I don't like to you know bother
people about it
um I've had my times where um I've I've
just started giving up in terms of like
you know I don't the Pain's been at
certain points in my life
um I've tried everything I might try the
stem cell thing
um I've been you know I've been stuck on
pills for a while and then I get
through that somehow and then and
ultimately I figure out that doesn't
work it's just numbing the pain or
masking once it goes into cute pain no
one no like I was I've never been
contrary to what people believe and how
they made me to look on American Idol
yeah without letting me know the red
lights on and me I'm a goofy girl I'm
needlessly I haven't even gotten into
American Idol but
pain is daunting and it's isolating
and
you may not like look
how awful you feel and the quality of
your life
becomes something that is so abnormal
and your pain tolerance it it's just
horrible and I you know I've gone
through 15 cervical spinal surgeries 15.
yes now let I want to get this out here
because people go
there's no record of her ever getting in
a crash landing and I was on tour my
first world tour big tour the biggest
tour uh touring act go and I was at the
height height of outselling a lot of
artists and I was leaving from St Louis
going to Denver in a seven-seater jet
private jet
and 30 minutes 35 minutes into the air I
had just gone to the bathroom and
climbed over luggage to get back to my
seat never got to my seat one of the
engines blew up in the right wing caught
on fire and we plummeted it
and I hit the top of my head on the
plane and I was knocked out
um
people say she's making this up you know
what these young reporters
don't realize
while I was on tour there was no
computer there were no Paparazzi it was
tabloid reporting
and after watching the horrific spinal
cord injuries that Gloria Stefan went
through a car crash for me I did my
whole career by myself I didn't have
anyone I could go to and say what was it
like for you because I started at 17
working with the most
genius ego maniacal like ego maniacal
genius uh I helped win Academy Awards
for these directors and producers Tony
Awards Emmys I worked with the cream of
the crop from time I was 17 years old
and and all of a sudden now
I'm in this in this crazy accident when
when I came to the plane was in flames
and there were six other people on the
plane
that experience this too there's no
reason I would make this up and have to
lose my career at the biggest catalog
selling art you were lying about because
it's because it's not documented
in in this is a private plane and
because I was able to have people sign
ndas I didn't want anyone to know that I
might perhaps be damaged goods I worked
really hard to get the career that I
have to go right to the hospital I was I
woke up in in the hospital I I was God
bless Merv Griffin's crew saw that a
private plane went down that it was mine
and they rescued us and and in in a
cornfield and I just I remember coming
to and like my tour manager was a guy
named Marty ham and I had this
incredible manager Bob Cavallo who was
managing prints at the time and and you
know wait a minute you know the first
thing I think of Ryan I know people are
thinking about it because I I'm a little
uh
morbid at times
but I I want to know what you're
thinking when you're looking
what you remember as you're going down
your your heart rate your your mind the
thoughts that go through your mind
because most people don't survive a
plane crash at least as far as I know
and that was the only one that didn't
have to see so what were you thinking
right before you remember waking up what
right I don't remember anything do you
remember anything in the plane I I
remember climbing over I remember it
seeing an illumination of light
and I saw my hair makeup artist who was
I had my hair makeup artist my tour
manager my tour accountant
um
I'm missing some people here I remember
seeing um my hair makeup guy Daniel a
light just illuminate his face and I I
saw fear of God and I I must have got
hit with my head and I was knocked out
you were surprised you you left well not
when I came I came too and and we were
all holding hands like I'm going wait
it's not our turn to go this is crazy
and we the co-pilot was able to crash
Landis did anybody die nobody died
um some people had stitches from a from
a dash over forehead uh gash on the knee
um but I was the only one that got
spinal cord injury and the thing you
want to hear a crazy thing I I was I had
already started a lot of my tour I had a
really incredible
um agent he wasn't my agent at CAA a guy
named Kevin hubane who just believed in
me and this is after the tremendous
successive bodyguard he said I just
watching Paul in her video she's an
actress
I know I want I want to gun for her I
was a client at CAA and I just had a
music agent you know Rob light and at
CAA but Kevin hubane kind of championed
me and got me in to read for a film and
it was the late Howard viewer who is the
casting director and I was told that
Academy Award winning Australian
director Stephen freers is directing
and I'm going to give you the punch line
at the end but I started coming in and
they would fly me on the northern part
of my tour I was going San Jose they'd
fly me back in at Paramount and I would
be reading with with Steven prayers with
with um Howard fuhrer and I'd see
different actresses from Patricia
Arquette and Winona like a lot of people
and I keep getting flown back to now I'm
I'm I'm screen testing
and I keep getting called back and now
it was down to two people
another actress
and me who is the actress Rosie Perez
Rosie Perez so now here's what happened
I screen tested with Jeff Bridges
I kept getting called back it was just
the weirdest thing so now it was down to
the two of us and Paramount I hadn't
done anything so they were skeptical and
they sent um Howard fine at the time
with like uh acting coach and a woman
named Janet alhanty who had contracts
with Paramount and wanted to know what
their opinion was because they got the
they got the nod from you know from
Howard from from Stephen but I
understood I didn't I have nothing that
I've proven myself with
so guess what I'm I have a day off in
Denver so I'm flying from St Louis after
my concert to Denver half hour in I get
in the plane crash landing wake up in
the hospital all I wake up to I said get
me out of the hospital I have to get to
the hotel room because they were flying
Howard and and Janet ahanty the two
acting coaches who Paramount and it was
from the movie Fearless
Jeff Bridges the plane crash movie
and I'm going method acting method
acting okay this is my role this is my
room oh my God but Rosie Perez no plus
the fact that with I had a cartoon lump
on my head like seriously a cartoon and
um but I was like Delirious thinking
this is it because I kept screen testing
it and thanks to Kevin huben that was
like but that's crazy so I can't make
these stories let me ask you this though
um was there a time where you just were
kind of like hey I needed I need like I
was hooked on pills for a while because
in my back but there were times when you
were had to go withdrawal and [__] well
here's the thing because I was the
perfect pain management patient at Cedar
Sinai
um I had never gone through anything
serious like this but like I I went
paralyzed my whole left the whole bright
side of my body and um
even like even partial like temporary
facial paralysis
um I was now damaged goods
um
and I got dropped from I was biggest
catalog selling artist I I ended up
having to be dropped by my record label
I remember I was dropped by my agency
and I learned how horrible this business
can be
um when you don't mean anything and you
can't deliver if you don't have
something to give people they don't need
you anymore they don't need you and
that's it's all yeah it's all very
superficial take you have to be tough to
whether this business you know people
people mistake that my kindness is
weakness so my kindness to me is King
because
you know it's easy to be someone like
the guy the British guy I sat next to
you and left me but it's yeah that's
another it's really it's really it takes
love it takes patience it takes
stick to itness and and the belief and
talent to to be able to
to weather [__] like that and and so now
when you go into acute pain as you have
experienced if you are now naturally
addicted to whatever pain management
pain medicine they're giving you so
I had never been on on
drugs to but I had nerve damage and
structural damage in order for your
nerves to grow back it's like watching
paint dry or grass grow it it's not an
easy thing and I went through
traveling the world and there was a
brand new thing called stem cell
research back then and I tried to get
into trials all over the world I went to
Dusseldorf I went to China I was in
Japan I I went to Thailand I I was in
Canada I yeah I kept getting cut from
the front
and each neurosurgeon said I've got I
have these plates that are going to be
perfect for you it never worked I get
few silly like uh scar tissue that would
wrap around like a fusilli noodle around
my spinal cord it was one failed surgery
afternoon these nerves nerves nerve
blocks nerve blocks
blocks like right you've had it all
still alive so so and then and here I am
in like 92 pounds taking
drugs having to be on Fentanyl patches
the the pain was on a scale of of 0 to
10 10 being natural childbirth my my
normal way of living for almost 17 years
was seven and a half
and yet I never gave up I always knew
that the most powerful muscle in your
body is your brain If I Could divert my
brain away from the energy of focusing
on pain
yourself
and but it was an upper total appeal oh
yeah you know I Disappeared for seven
seven years a little like seven years
three months three and a half months
you know that's a long time to be away
from the business however I had the
biggest catalog so I was the biggest
catalog selling artist at the time with
my debut album so but
seven and a half years you know people
go away and stuff and I showed showed up
on a brand new show
it's called American Idol
and it was like you were it was like
yesterday they saw you here we are oh
yeah Paul it became well no it was it
was touted is going to be the most
Velveeta Cheesy
show that's going to ruin the music I
was watching that show I couldn't stop
watching it for years it became like the
Death Star like to every other network
if a Network dropped 50 in all their
ratings we still were like 100 you know
it's funny because
um when I was doing Smallville I
remember them saying oh well all our
other shows there were kind of tanking
so this is helping us Break Even I'm
like what it was just weird so American
Idol was that show you know the only
thing I think about is I remember like
people remember how nasty Simon could be
of course how sweet and lovable you are
and how laid back and cool Randy was I
just sounded like Morgan Freeman by the
way Morgan Freeman oh but yeah I
remember the first day I met Anthony
that's good you're good but no so when I
look back I remember going why he's so
mean like
I know he stuck up for you a lot too
what did he not what are you smoking I
thought I read somewhere where like when
I don't know like he stuck up with you
about the whole thing with the the guy
one of the contestants and he had your
back so he didn't have your back oh my
God I'm wrong I I guess you're watching
a different version so you didn't get
along with him oh it was like brother
sister kind of like when you say brother
sister are you sugar coating it because
it was like half brother half sister I
don't really know you I can't stand
Satan yeah Satan
um it was it was probably the most
difficult job
challenging job that I I've ever had in
my career every day when you were on
your way to work were you having anxiety
and stress because you had to deal with
that I'll tell you I started the first
season the first month going to therapy
once a week when it was going eight
times a week there was something wrong
this I'm telling you I
you never ever read about me being a
partier because I'm not I've been
working professionally since I'm 17
years old right
in real heavy situations with James L
Brooks Oliver Stone uh you know Rob
Reiner well now what's your name who
directed big I didn't that's I knew
where you said there was a big mistake
with that they lied it's not I didn't
choreograph big what ended up happening
is I did a Diet Coke commercial with
Elton and I danced on a piano yes that's
right and then it was at that then then
that's what they think of it as and so
big ended up saying oh well there's a
you know that must be a great scene uh
so I it wasn't me it was just because it
is the doors real
I did choreograph the doors and Oliver
Stone is a historian it was a different
kind of choreography that I said do I
really have to do this but I turned Val
Kilmer into Jim Morrison and because
Oliver Stone is such a stickler for
history I he gave me
boatloads of tapes of watching the doors
and watching Jim Morrison be drugged out
of his mind body surfing
tipping over I had to recreate every
Nuance of how Jim Morrison stumbled
performed one of the toughest jobs
because Val Kilmer also was
a natural genius was he tough to work
with
it was not it was not the most Pleasant
job for me um because I'm dealing with
an amazing actor who actually can sing
like I know I know that whole story yeah
he sent tapes to Oliver Stone album
Stone didn't know who was listening to
and it was actually about Cameron
singing the door songs Oliver Stone was
like it was in between actors and it was
you work with these actors tell me what
I mean I'm 17 and have 18. 19 years old
when I'm working with all these James L
Brooks and and all these people being
given tremendous responsibility and me
and me and all the while
I remained as the Laker girl and and
choreographer because I was afraid I'd
lose my day job so I became the biggest
choreographer
um choreographing
Janet Jackson
Coming to America a lot of people don't
know that I could choreographed the big
African wedding scene and coming to
America to this day was that big money
when they ask you to choreograph stuff I
thought I thought did I just die and go
to heaven I cannot believe I'm making
this kind of money that kind of money
for doing these big movies well do you
get she gets paid by you probably worked
for weeks on something yeah because
um I was given the response bill first
of all I was called in by John Landis
too well let me get back to Oliver Stone
we're going to get back to Simon Cowell
just in a second too go ahead this is a
problem with my life story it's uh
you're coming back there's too much it's
too much to talk about I haven't even
gotten I know you know but like and the
fact that my roommates well after I had
I lived with four Laker Girls
I got them all their sad cards and aptra
and I said I have I have to hire other
dancers and they would I'd have the
old-fashioned machine and you have the
the you know checking your messages and
I get to the two-bedroom apartment and
my like your girl roommates are going
okay
um George Michael's manager called you
need to be at Sony I choreographed the
face tour what yes
and then um
Prince wants to meet with you you're
going to have to go to
Sony and um you've got rehearsals with
you got the Tracy Allman show that was a
brand new show I won an Emmy for that
two Emmys from shut up
sorry I'm a little [__]
with you are I mean I just let's get
there's so much I want to talk to you
about so as someone who's interviewing
you and talking with you and Whoopi
Goldberg was my roommate
I started throwing the eye in there from
four Laker Girls to how old were you
when she was your roommate I was
22 at the time 20. did she like you I
love Whoopi did she like me yeah she
love me she hated my pug
because the Pug would jump in the pool
Jesus let me just ask you you jumped
away it was my fault probably sorry but
listen when you were talking about Simon
you said you got up to maybe going to
therapy like eight times a day I'm
joking but I'm joking but you but like
you know it was I never experienced
anything like that what was it was it
just when you saw him you get anxiety
were you intimidated by him because I
think I'd be maybe intimidated by him he
won a
you know I have crazy stories and
they're long and crazy and I tried not
but but if I don't tell you how I got
American Idol which is the craziest
story of forget Laker girl that's like a
pimple on an elephant's behind compared
to how I got are you are you going are
you yeah I'm listen you got to steer me
here because I'm just so much my life
about Simon are you done talking about
no I'm not done talking about that
because it's how I got the job
so Ryan we're going to go a little over
on this one great too interesting you
know I'll I'll no it's I just love it
okay I can talk to you forever I didn't
realize how
I just always when I met you how I
pictured you was just very
you know
you're not loud I'm saying I can't think
I can't think of a better word than sort
of reserved and very and you are and
very uh classy in all these things but
when you get going you're like a kid and
you and you tell these stories and like
I just don't want these stories to stop
but
um it's awesome so go ahead where do you
what do you want to talk about do you
know it's crazy it's crazy tell me a
short story how you became got American
Idol
so I am literally
in crying pain quality of life sucks in
and out of surgery after surgery blowing
money money from all these surgeries and
all this [__]
horrific quality of life trying to
divert my energy away from pain
all of a sudden I'm in one of I'm I'm I
think I was in Canada when I got a phone
call because I oh I forgot to tell you
on my 12th surgery a neurosurgeon cut me
the wrong way and I got this like it's
called RSD which is horrific it's it's
on the scale of natural childbirth and
it's horrible your body can't even it's
it's spinal cord injury your body can't
handle the amount of pain you break out
in lesions like like horrible shingles
open sores and then whenever it wants to
die down it magically goes back in your
skin as no scar it was like the craziest
pain and every doctor neurosurgeon
stayed away from you stay safe because
it's there's no cure right all right so
at the worst and worse times while this
is going on I have a song and songs that
I had been working on but I can't
because he cut when he did that he also
scraped my vocal cords now I don't even
have a speaking voice let alone
bad joke
that's okay
it wasn't it wasn't great but it was you
know sometimes I just said the 14 year
old in me comes out I get it yeah we'll
cut it that thirteen dollars a name go
ahead go ahead so worst time of your
life the vocal cords all these things
what happens I
was going to New York to meet with my
publisher because now I'm in a
predicament
I can't work I can't I can't re I
recorded background vocals on certain
songs there was a song I want was
working on that
it was a retro disco type of feel song
that I wanted to do about my divorce
okay and it was I wanted to be fun but
it was like kind of like a
but it was a great dance record and I
met
um I remember saying you know to my
publisher can I sell some songs and
it and I remember I was in pain and my
Publisher's greatest guy in the world
Evan Lamberg and uh he knew what I was
going through and
it's just so weird because it was a
rainy rainy day I had to get back to LA
I'm terrible pain and I go sh I'm gonna
miss my flight I can't get a cab I gotta
call the hotel book it I mean the
pouring rain it's the wind chill factor
my umbrella is like torqued upside down
and broken and I'm soaking wet and this
girl literally crosses the street walks
up to me and says
are you Paula Abdul I said yeah and she
goes oh yeah she goes my boss has a
framed thank you letter from you he has
no thank you letters from any other
artist yours is frame I go who do you
work for she goes the president of
billboard magazine Michael Lewis I go oh
my God I remember writing him a letter
because he gave me a really
Fair equally pointed
critique that from Madison Square Garden
I believe it was Madison Square Garden
and he pointed out real strengths that
puts me in a lane of my own and real
weaknesses that I'm aware of and I've
learned how to
get over the whatever bad you know
review you get you gotta understand you
gotta remove the things that you have no
business even caring about if they
attack you on the personal level
um it's none of your business but the
things things you can improve you have
to take the instructive criticism
constructive criticism and he was really
equally fair and I thought when you
remember that I remember and I I wrote a
handwritten thank you
I go wow I remember that I go what are
you on lunch break I'm like she goes
yeah I go well I'm missing my flight you
want to have lunch with me she goes
you're [__] me I don't know she goes
God you really are the girl that
you seem to be and I'd say Brooklyn
Diners right across the street let's
have lunch Brooklyn Diner
and I said so are you an aspiring singer
songwriter she goes everyone is who
works at billboard but we can't solicit
ourselves and I go I hear you I go are
you good
she goes oh I'm damn good
I went wow I go well you you said you
live close can you bring me some of your
demos she goes really I just tell me
what you want and on napkin I wrote what
she wanted to eat she went she came back
she goes I can't believe I'm doing this
I listen literally
four bars in I took the head the
headphone off I said you are that good
I said wow I said
she goes I go I'm going to be coming
back and she goes where be like where
where have you been I said I explained
to her
been a really tough road for me
um I've been I sustained so many bad
injuries and surgeries and she was like
I go but I but I want to reserve three
songs that I just heard because I will
be getting a record deal I will be doing
that
she goes are you kidding me I said no I
said also I want to put it out there
that
if you really are serious about this I
will let you come and stay with me in LA
and I'll introduce you to riding camps
and things like that and I said I'll I
ask is that you'd give enough notice to
Mike Ellis if this and two weeks later
she said are you still willing to I said
absolutely and she gave enough notice
that Mike Ellis and Mike Ellis had said
of course it's Paula
I moved a complete stranger her name was
Kara
I okay this is important she comes to
live with me the first week she's living
with me in my condominium in West
Hollywood
I from like a recommendation from
Jim Brooks from James L Brooks talking
about psychic this woman in the
at you know she's apparently great you
should go see her I had maybe been a
couple of psychics in my life not and I
but it was like I uh it was already paid
for
and I decided to go okay I decided to go
I said Karen you want to come with me
sure
so it's this amazing woman named Dolores
Catalucci
Italian broad a woman who finds missing
children and works for the police
station she's an amazing psychic and she
said she's in Van Nuys like in on
Calvert Street
you stay in your car until I call you
when I call you get out of the car
well obviously because I saw
Brad Pitt and Jennifer Aniston walking
out of this house like major people and
like so you walk in the first thing she
does and she goes give me give me a kiss
give me Jeweler give me your phone give
me something I she disappears less than
30 seconds later she comes back she goes
put your tape recorder on get your pet
start writing and she starts spewing out
a whole bunch of information
and she says
you've had a rough go at this you're
you're gonna be okay
it's your health is gonna figure itself
out you're gonna be okay not without
struggle and she started talking to me
about my dad and that my dad was going
to develop dementia and he did and
Alzheimer's she told me that my sisters
can be in full remission from breast
cancer that happened
and then she told me you're going to be
doing a TV show and I'm going fantastic
and I'm thinking okay it's this MTV show
that I pitched right she goes no no
that's not that one and she goes look
she she goes it's a talent show I go
look like Star Search goes I don't know
but it's it's gonna be the biggest thing
of your career you think music's big
really she said all this not only did
she say all of this she went as far as
telling me that I'm going to be sitting
next
to it a hole from across the pond
and eight and then African-American guy
that you somehow know
I'm like I'm not even paying attention
because I'm not like I'm not doing a
time that's crazy not doing a talent
show
and she goes honey you willed it to
happen I I can I read from
three years from now to three years and
I you willed it to happen how long after
you saw her did you get this call almost
three years later
so
remember oh she asked me do you want do
you want her to be in your reading I
said I don't care yeah fine so Cara was
in the reading with me
I forget about all of this I'm paying
attention to my sister self and my dad's
health
um
to watch your dad because he's gonna
start losing his motor skills and he's
gonna fall and break his ankle or
something and he did it was just it was
sad things were happening I didn't I
never paid attention to what she said I
had a tape recording of it I had notes
from it
and um
two and a half years later
weirdest thing I get a phone call from
my attorney and business manager saying
and my publisher
because what I didn't tell you is when I
missed my flight and I had to stay over
another hotel
Cara
worked on this uh song for my post
divorce the the Vintage you know retro
disco song that was doing about Emilio
Estevez no no the the second one that I
don't get to I don't even have to talk
about because it was another one but we
we finished a song and that was how I'm
and then two two and a half three weeks
ago she was living with me and she was
in that reading with me and I I
introduced her to
different writing camps of people that I
know
um she was a funny roommate uh and the
reason I'm telling you all this because
you know my stories are crazy as they
are
two and a half years later I get a call
I'm in a hot I'm I'm in the hospital
bed and my publisher first says this
not my attorney my publisher said are
you sitting down little did he know I
was two days out of yet now my
11th or 12th surgery 13th surgery it was
like towards tail end of
them I go yeah he goes that song that
you worked on with Kara
um
I pitched it to an artist that was huge
before you ever came out Paula but
Australian Locomotion Kylie mcnog he
goes yes she's on a very small label
called London Beat Records and loves the
song and she removed
scratchly vocals she put her lead vocal
on
and he goes Paula it looks like it's
gonna enter the charts number one in the
UK
blessing
Kara's first number one record it was
with you
for another artist that was given to
Kylie Minogue
it went number one in every territory
except it wasn't released in one
territory the United States a song
called spinning around
now
that's the first number one for her
for Cara and it's a a Renaissance for
Kylie Minogue because now her world
explodes to have the coming from when I
hear Underdog Story I'm like give it
give it I'm all about the underdog
now because of that
several months later I get a call from
my attorney and business major going
Paula you need to sign off on licensing
and Mechanicals for the song that you
did with Kara and this guy IRA and it's
um
it it's there's it's for a show in the
UK
some kind of talent show nothing's going
off in my brain no Dolores Catalucci and
there was another psychic named Miss
Faye out here who I saw that predicted
the same exact thing all within a
relatively one year Time same thing same
people all right keep going with this so
now I'm going uh I go can I get the
number of the producer you're talking to
and my attorney my publisher everyone
who's worked with me my agents they know
I'm tenacious
I'm looking for a way to
help
these artists I hear it's a talent show
and guess what
every kid in this new
UK show called pop Idol
is coming in and auditioning singing
acapella spinning around
the song that was went number one that
from Cara myself and this guy IRA
now
I call this woman I keep getting hung up
on because they don't believe it's me
it's not not the opal it's it's not you
polar that kind of stuff and it's like
oh my God and I keep calling and finally
I I just started humming straight up
and I could hear the phone
because it's her it's her and this woman
Claire Howell got on the phone who's the
producer and she went and on I said I
would love to somehow get involved and
help
keep I'm a choreographer and I work with
artists I work with Michael for Jackson
for six years George Michael I give
signature let me work with I'm thinking
anything and everything I can to get
away from I'm in the hospital right now
on my 12th surgery 13th surgery
she goes oh my God that would be
fantastic she goes listen we're at still
she was English why I what what accent
am I doing now
oh did I go into it no go ahead go ahead
I'm back to the American because I'd
like to save the British first Simon
um
she went on to say that you know we just
begun it's the biggest show in the UK
the queen clears her diary to vote
I went what oh yes the country boats I
went huh she goes and it's brutal you
know everyone talks behind you back in
in America but here
there are these two wretched guys
one is a big producer named Pete
Waterman I go I know Pete Bananarama Ace
of Base and this other guy who's an a r
executive named Simon Cowell they're
horrible they make young men fall to
their knees crying in embarrassment
because they they tell you that you suck
I went oh my God and there's a really
sweet girl in the middle
who's a radio DJ
and it's hosted by these two Comedians
and I said I said well I would love to
she goes listen when we get down to the
top 20 or top 12 or whatever we'll fly
you out here to work with the kids I'm
great I great I go in the meantime can
you send me any any tapes because I I
don't know what the show looks like and
later on I got sent some tapes to look
at and um
I watched and I saw how wretched it was
I was like in shock but I didn't hear
back from Claire
until
I just accepted
choreographing even with because the
beauty of choreographing I could be God
forbid confined to a wheelchair God
forbid I still can choreograph and and
my dancers know my lingo my language and
I you know it's it that's a beautiful
thing and I was still coming out of
surgeries and I just signed on to do
Dana carvey's uh comeback movie after
yet
the wrong part of his body operated
remember when well okay it was Master of
Disguise I just signed on principal
photography photography starting I get a
call from this woman Claire Howell we're
ready to bring it to London I said I
can't I darn I can't just no worries no
worries the show is the biggest show in
the world I bet you there's gonna be a
bidding work we'll be in we coming to
America within nine months two years and
I did
I forgot all about that
and then I get a call
it's almost two it's almost three years
today it's almost a year from when
Claire house said she would call me
and I get a call from not Claire
after she after I said you know I can do
Master of Disguise
almost a year later I get a call from my
from my business manager and attorney
saying
Fox is trying to get a hold of you they
want you to come down and and interview
for a TV show
I go what kind of TV show uh it's it's
their new division like of reality shows
and like all that we knew about was was
you all the weakest link like that was
Ann Robinson and that was the first
brutal take on what this one right so
I'm hearing it's a talent show I don't
put I don't I'm not thinking Dolores
cartelucci I'm not thinking Miss Faye
I'm not thinking of the tapes right and
so you go in I go in and
Nigel let's go there's like 18 people
from Fremantle and producers and fox
producers an Egypt audition or you just
no I was called in so I was called in
and I'm not thinking about anything and
then I'm then I hear
it's there's a wretched guy named Simon
Cowell and I'm still not putting two and
two together
and then there is
there are these two uh hosts one is a DJ
radio DJ at Coast 103 FM a new new guy
named Ryan Seacrest and and this this
budding comedian that's won the Aspen
Comedy Fest name Brian dunkelman and I'm
I'm just I'm listening all this oh and
that and there and then you're sitting
in between
Simon Cowell the Retro guy and an
African-American uh uh Randy Jackson not
the fat member of The Jacksons but
another that member like that's what
they said this is like I'm going I'm in
shock right okay so it's not the mem not
the fat member of The Jacksons and I'm
going does he not know that I worked
with the Jacksons like rude and I'm
going this guy is bold and then all of a
sudden
pull it start flying George cartellucci
Claire Howell Miss babe oh [__] Simon
Cowell uh like everything starts made
sense yeah my heart is in my feet now
because I willed this to happen I will
this happen that's why I was told
how did I will this to happen nothing's
making sense to me other than if this is
supposed to be my job why am I feeling
so shitty right and what ended up
happening was
I said when is this job starting well
that's the thing Paula you got to pack
your bags because in three days we go to
our first city of auditions
now I'm annoying it's it's that pop Idol
show oh my God every
but why is this bill so bad I said when
is it starting three days I said
you know I'm really sorry but I have
fiduciary responsibilities that I bought
and I said I wish I would have known
earlier and I'm dying inside because I'm
still thinking right of the missiles
that's right it's never enough it's like
there's just some stupid there's an old
show called Eight is Enough I remember
right and there was a yeah I wrote this
script that got sold but never got made
but I remember the two kind of has-bins
on the show that I wrote I love husbands
well they're they're guys that had been
something and they're not and they're
looking at the TV and he's like Willie
Ames was an actor on that show Eight is
Enough he goes Willie Ames man whatever
happened to Willie Ames he's like dude
he did Charles in Charge he did this he
did this isn't that enough and I go
Eight is Enough
that's really stupid moment but it's so
true how you could be famous and do all
these things where's that guy where's
where's she now why isn't success
success because you're you're taught in
this business that no [__] that change
the change the trajectory of it if you
were successful you've made it 100 not
you were famous you made it that's the
way these the business wants to make you
feel but the truth of the matter is you
got to believe in yourself you gotta you
gotta stand in that light and know hey
I I broke the odds like I'm in I'm in
the less than one percentile who oh my
God you know what I mean it's like
you're you're like when I told my
friends Paul Abdul's come to the house
to uh to inter be interviewed they're
like what I interviewed so many people
and they're like oh that's cool dude
really cool man and sometimes I get
really key for Sutherland that's cool
but when I said Paula Abdul
they're like you're [__] kidding me
right now like you're like
just to have a name Paula Abdullah what
you've done and what you've accomplished
I hope you know and you should know that
it's just like that's enough oh that is
you have done I'm so crazy listen this
has been the longest interview I've ever
done I'm really sorry no it's not yeah
my life story is no little no
you don't understand I've already
thought of filming this movie called
Paula and the movie starts out with
narration and hang on and then you see
this little girl she's like I had I was
born prematurely I had this blah blah I
had this breathing thing when I inhale
blah blah and all of a sudden it shows
you Pat going uh I got
three to one says she's gonna pass out
before she gets to the and it shows you
this little girl in these leotards and
boom passes out and then she passes out
somewhere else and it shows you rapidly
growing up and all that [__] I could see
it my last question to you and and we
gotta make it short is
just because I want to talk to you again
because you're awesome to talk to but
when the Simon Cowell stuff you didn't
really get into that other than you had
anxiety and things like that but just if
you can kind of like did you ever get
through that with him did you ever
confront each other and kind of make it
cool was there ever a moment where like
I can't I can't work with him I'm not
going on stage I'm not doing this kind
of wrap that up you know it's like
look I've been working since I was a kid
and I've been working in really high
pressure adults you know how to deal
with it
but I'd never gone first of all reality
TV live live live was a brand new thing
so it's it's an it's awkward it's
intimidating you don't know I had to
learn oh my God if we're typing in front
of a live audience they can alter and
edit my words to not eat I I'll never
forget having Entertainment Tonight in
my house in the living room with my
family and I can't wait because I work
for Entertainment Tonight I'm going guys
wait till you hear
what Simon Says and how I defend this
amazing girl
they cut it
I I had I was saying like this is the
most insane statement you could ever
make that all you have to say is your
look like a fat version of Jessica
Simpson how can you say that she said
that he said that yes oh yes and that
was cut and all of that's cut and this
is what you see
you're so pretty
look but you know what the truth of the
matter is I've always been the girl that
I am I mean you are an idol and you are
amazing and it's fun meeting you at the
this Con that I met you at and it was
your first con it was in Pittsburgh and
I see you just
so many people over there and you're
signing autographs and you're making so
many people happy do you get anxious at
these cons or do you feel you love being
around the fans is it something new to
you and that you want to experience more
I I'm a people person
um obs
as you are too
um I love being able to meet people that
have like so richly honored me and and
paid paid honor and respect and and have
been there as fans for so long it's
overwhelming when you see you know
you're kind of sandwiching it in the
area in your backs against the wall and
all of these people it's and you're up
close and personal with them it's it's a
little overwhelming it's a little
overwhelming but it was it was a great
gift because anytime I can connect and
and make a difference and and be present
to acknowledge these amazing people who
have stood by me and beside me
it's awesome well look
I mean there's some you're coming back
will you come back you asked me up my
life story do you know Richard Branson
who signed me by the way I was one of
the first four artists that Richard
Branson signed and Virgin Records Was a
studio apartment on Sunset and Doheny
they signed Roy Orbison
Steve Winwood a group called The Cutting
Crew and
and Paul Abdul
um
for like I knew I'm the underdog I know
this position very well right throw me
up against the wall see if I Steve it
sticks and when I tell you the ROI of
what they gave me and what they would
say oh the airline that Paula built oh
the Frank Lloyd Wright building is that
ball built the Mercedes and the
Rolls-Royce it's like the joke was that
within a year and a half time from like
under a hundred thousand dollars to an
entire album which I Bartered deals on
and and said Prince I'll you write the
song for me I'll choreograph
just making deals to get things made and
teaching cheerleading camps and dance
camps and just to make ends meet to make
your dreams come true and you know what
um in a year and a half Roy Orbison died
that year and sold a million albums they
had a platinum record and Steve Winwood
uh I think sold a million albums and
then I broke records as a debut artist
um the biggest biggest album and and by
the way
everyone says well
because she's a video artist
well people the truth is is that my all
of my songs went number one and I was
scrambling to catch up and make a video
that's why my album stayed on the charts
record-breaking amount of time because I
had number one songs and I had three
weeks later or a month later would come
a video which prolonged the success wow
well look I love the story you've done
we're gonna get into it but it's like
your residency in Vegas your jewelry
your your GE you have a clothing we
don't I mean there's so many things you
go to your Instagram there's just like
it's it's endless anyone it's the groove
gear collection right yeah and you have
these glasses do you want to hear the
craziest thing no artist can say like no
no um so Richard Branson signs me
success Beyond success
uh last April I got a call from Richard
Branson's office and and Richard wanted
to know if I'd give him permission to
name his next rocket straight up
I went watched the rocket get built I
was there I filmed I actually saw my
rocket straight up take launch on July
1st who gets to say that that is
beautiful well look this has been a damn
Joy I'm gonna hold you to it if you're
gonna come back and we're going to talk
more this is uh this is awesome thank
you this has been great this has been
really really fun and great for me too
so thank you and we never we we made the
time because we don't we usually do them
in the morning late morning but this is
kind of like a Friday early evening
special before the weekend get started
it's like the Jazz session yeah I like
it all right I love you thanks for
letting me know thank you
ah I loved it she was so sweet but you
know after that she's like text me we'll
go out to dinner and she never texts me
back
busy
Paul Abdul that has been busy for a long
time
that's Abdul [__] right there uh thank
you Paul for coming on the show I love
you you're fantastic you're beautiful
you're a talent that needs to be
recognized and is recognized and um just
so much going on with her
um she said she'll come back on and talk
more about Simon and stuff so that was
fun uh if you want to listen to any of
the other stuff that I mentioned in the
intro do it inside of you online store
patreon.com talkfill and one of the
perks for the patrons is I get to give
shout outs to your names to all my
favorite people here uh if you want to
become a patron uh support the podcast
we need you here we go Nancy D Leah s
little Lisa Yukiko Jill e uh Brian h
Nico P Robert B Jason W Sophie M Raj C
Joshua D Jennifer and Stacy L Jamal F
Janelle B Mike e l Don Supremo Raj and
other horror people Leanne likes horror
and uh there's some others that like har
Brian and cam
um Nico but there's this movie called I
I see you it's on Netflix I I had fun
with it there's a lot of you know
there's a lot of problems with it but it
was kind of fun I kind of liked it uh
the movie air is Awesome by the way go
see air oh gosh 99 more Santiago M
Santiago the uh the bust here is awesome
if you guys can see that in the distance
it's the Smallville bust right you want
to hold that so Santiago made this bust
and it is just freaking fantastic and
he's also making me some inside of you
like uh figures that I'm gonna put on
the site it's uncanny I mean look at
that oh it's kind of creepy looking at
myself all right there you go
be careful break
Chad W Liam P Janine R Maya P Maddie s
Belinda and Dave H hello Dave hole how
are you mate I love you man
Sheila G Brad d Ray tab of the T Tom and
Liliana a Target
um these names that's their family Betsy
D Chad L Angel amerian and see Cory okay
Deb next and Michelle a Jeremy C Brandy
D Joey M Eugene and Leah Corey Heather L
Jake B Megan T Angela F Mel s Orlando C
Caroline R uh Christine s Eric H Shane R
Andrew M Tim L Karina Ann Amanda R gen B
Kevin e Stephanie K Jor L jam and J
Leanne J Luna R Cindy e Mike F Stone H
Miss s Brian L Katie B
Aaron at R Aaron R
uh Kendall L I love the newbies too
house J Meredith I Charlene C Kara C
Mary R Sheena L Jessica B Kyle F Marisol
p s Devon G Kaylee J Megan K Mickey L
and Brian a could not do this podcast
without you guaranteed so thank you for
your love and support and I love you and
from the Hollywood Hills in Southern
California Michael Michael Rosenbach
a little way to the camera we love you
guys please please please be good to
yourself be good to yourself
foreign